the jogan experience I just remember
this guy's like rich just hold like
these [__] paintings and just stand
on the street like a homeless man and
he's just [__] just want everybody to
see his painting yeah he's just nuts he
just he's just [__] Rich crazy guy
with way too much time on his hands and
when I saw that I was like bro like once
you reach a level of money like you
probably just do crazy [__] just for the
[__] out just for just because you can
you know what I mean especially if all
you do is make money like that's what
those dominatrix ladies always say their
clients are always these guys are like
these CEOs of Mega corporations and they
just want to get pissed on and yelled at
slap [__] nuts yeah they want to get
tied up and thrown in the corner shut
the [__] up they come over and kick them
in the balls they want that bro did you
uh you seen that movie I mean it's like
they made the movie about the movie The
Room yeah that was that Tommy Wu or
what's his name I don't remember his
name I was messed it up but there's that
scene
in the movie that made fun of the movie
where like Joe Rogan's character like
the director goes to the bank and he's
like I want to cash this check and
they're like all right yeah and he's
like holy [__] it worked and the the
bank teller's telling him he's just like
this guy's bank account it's like a
bottomless pit that amount of money has
to be kind of scary though cuz you
either go make shitty movies with your
money then you don't know what the [__]
you're doing like that guy which is
funny or you probably also do scary [__]
like that's a scary amount of money to
have so I know I know people who like
you know struggle financially probably
like oh man if I could just have this
money if I could just have that money
like yeah life would be easier but if
there's no challenge if there's no maze
to run through what are you really going
to do with that much free time I'll tell
you what you're going to do you're going
to get in a homemade submarine and die
in the ocean you see what I'm saying
like yeah those dudes that's exactly
what that was like that was
$250,000 a ticket to get in that
submarine and die why and the submarine
had no windows right well it had like
little small Windows you don't really
see you're seeing things through a
screen they call me old school but I
feel like if I spent $250,000 on the
ticket I want like a luxurious
experience I want to see the [__]
ocean not through a tiny little screen I
want communication with the outside
world like I don't know I am I I do want
to get rich don't get me wrong I do want
to get rich cuz I feel like pretty soon
there you know what are you going to buy
what kind of car are you going to get I
mean I'm not too worried about all that
I really want to save money like
painting don't you want a do I want to
go to the Moon oh you're one of those
dudes yeah Elon Musk is probably going
to offer rides to you know 250 bucks
250,000 a ticket I think you could
already get into space for that amount
of cheddar yeah yeah I think you can get
into space for like 250 I want to go to
space like the blue origin don't they
fly people into space bro you want to
wait a few years yeah yeah I definitely
want them to get the Kinks out you know
me work out the glitches you don't want
you don't want to die in a fiery ball of
hell yeah crashing into the ocean
Burning Alive N yeah uh blue origin for
suborbital flights blue origin typically
charges around $200 to $300,000 per
person the cost includes a 1-hour flight
and a 3-hour preparation program for
those looking to go into orbit blue orb
Origins orbital launch Services range
from 50 million to 100 million per
person yo that's a big difference that
is a giant difference all right
suborbital is that good you go up for I
think they send you up for about a
minute or two and then you just float
back down back down how far do you go
what's the height what's suborbital
suborbital means you're not going out
technically of the range where you need
to go you're going very very high that's
like where they sent sh shatter to I
think is that where they send the guy
remember the guy who Sky Dove from the
outer layer wild [__] for Red
Bull or whatever yeah that's my friend
yeah that's Andy stump man he's a
psychopath was it Andy that did that's a
different guy Andy did but Andy did
something similar he was on a [__]
plane so there's suborbital right here
okay this is sub orbital so they're
still floating
so they're above Earth they get to look
down they're weightless look at William
Shatner he's like I'm too old for this
[__] but you don't you don't get way up
there where you're looking down on the
ball I don't even think that's fun right
there cuz are you even it's like I feel
like the Earth is so bright you can't
even see the stars and [__] you
definitely probably won't see a star
there no you don't see the stars that's
not worth I'm not doing that but I think
to see the stars you got to go way I
yeah I don't know they're even seeing
them in the spaceship you got to go way
the [__] up there I want to go into like
the abyss you probably do when you're on
the dark side don't you think Jamie yeah
but how many no one's been there for a
long time right but you go over there
for a whiz right like it's real fast
you're going like 177,000 miles an hour
right isn't that the space station yeah
I honest I'm I mean we'd have I could
look we have to look into this I think
the only star you could probably see is
the
sun oh it's to when you're on the other
side changing my
financial you got to get 100 million
bucks bro you got to go way up I wonder
how much it cost for them to send me to
like a wormhole or a black hole well you
don't want to do that n n n if if I'm
like imagine come you come back and
you're in the Mongol days you're like
[__] what is the Mongol days
like when gask Khan ruled the Earth and
killed 10% of the population that would
suck it suck took I don't know I'd hope
not even to come back though I just go
somewhere else maybe there's like
another planet Another Universe another
dimension yeah yeah I don't know maybe
remember when Bradley Cooper went
through it and then he came back and
Earth was like saved but they're like
living in the like cylinder fourth
dimension things or something like that
was it Interstellar you see Interstellar
oh that wasn't Bradley Cooper that was
Matthew MCC right Matthew MCC I get name
was confused yeah BR Cooper will get his
chance too but yeah Matthew mccon yeah
that was a great movie bro even he got
back in the ship and was like nah I'm
out so yeah okay during Space Walk in
Earth's Shadow astronauts Can See Stars
once their eyes adjust to the darkness
holy [__] your eyes have to adjust to
the darkness of space but that's space
walks in Earth's Shadow I don't think
that's the same they don't go behind the
moon though space station habitable
artificial satellite and low earth orbit
that serves a space environment that
ship that trip I've told you about a few
times that uh Steve aoke is supposed to
go on it's supposed to be like one of
the first man trips back around the moon
since Steve yoke don't die on the moon
bro I've said this to him before let me
say it again don't do it buddy that guy
is [__] badass he's badass he's a
cool dude too you know a l the moon he's
very cool I don't on crew for first
mission to the Moon Steve you want to be
on the 100th Mission but by the way I
think they did a hundred of those
submarine Dives before that one exploded
oh [__] I think they did a bunch of them
damn it wasn't like they were the first
people they probably go you got the
Kinks worked out I'll try this [__]
out I've done it a hundred times what
could go wrong [__] up even car
accidents happen every
day